نحن في المملكه اليوم
90% من صادراتنا سبعين في الميه من
الواردات تمر من خلال المعاناه اليوم 13
ميناء طبعا ما شاء الله السواحل في
المملكه كبيره
3400 كيلو متر سبعه موانئ على البحر
الاحمر اكبر ميناء ميناء جده الاسلامي
اكبر ميناء في المملكه واكبر ميناء على
البحر الاحمر من متكامل في كل انواع
البضائع ورغم كل ذلك
ميناء واحد في دبي اكبر من شغل كل مانع
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه ونعم الجريسي
يستضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده
الراي وسولف معهم على المستجدات ومستهدفات
رؤيه السعوديه 2030 طيب حلقه اليوم هو
الاستاذ عمر حريري رئيس الهيئه العامه
للموانع الموانع تمثل جزء مهم في الركيزه
الثالثه من ركائز
محور ربط القارات 90% من واردات السعوديه
من البضائع تمر من خلال الموانع 70% من
صادرات السعوديه تمر من خلال موانئ
فالموانئ بوابه جدا مهمه تحدثنا عن موضوع
الموانئ بشكل عام جهاز الموانئ السعوديه
بشكل خاص تاريخها المراحل الاربعه اللي مر
فيها
والتحديات السابقه اللي خلت السعوديه بحجم
اقتصادها الهائل بكل موانئها
اقل في عدد الحاويات من ميناء واحد في
مدينه واحده في دوله مجاوره وبعد ذلك
تكلمنا على اهم التحولات والاصلاحات اللي
صارت في موضوع سرعه الفتح سرعه دوران
الشاحنات او الشاحنات سرعه دوران السفن
وكذلك
اتمتت ورقمنه الاجراءات في عمليه فسح
الموانئ وتخصيص الخدمات الموجوده فيها ثم
ختمنا بمجموعه من اسئلتكم الثمينه مثل ليش
ما فيش استراتيجيه خاصه بالموانع وكيف
نسلم اكبر ميناء في السعوديه
يشغلوا اكبر منافس لنا في المنطقه
الى بقيه اسئلتكم الثمينه اترككم مع
الحوار حياك الله ابو طلال شرفتونا
ونورتنا الله يحييك وشكرا على الكريمه
شكرا لك على الرغم من العرض الصحي فسلامتك
لكن ان شاء الله
بطاقه تكفي لاخر الحلقه ان شاء الله الحمد
لله ان الله يعافيك وطبعا ودي ابدا بسالك
عن التناقض غريب شوي
هوايه الجولف معروف انها كذا حقت طبقه
اصحاب الدخل العالي واصحاب الشريحه
مجتمعيه معينه
وانت لعبتها مره مرات حافي الظاهر اللي هي
سلوك نشوفه في الحواري ونشوفه في يعني
شرائح مختلفه من مجتمع ايش دخل الجولف
باللعب حافي
وكيف هالهوايه دخلتك على عالم لوجستيات
هذه قصه اكثر من 26 سنه ما شاء الله عليك
يعني قدرت تجيبها بس انا بديت القول في
عمري
انا في الرياض
كان الملعب المتاح في وقت الملعب
فندق الانتركو ملعب صغير يعني ما هو في
مقاييس دوليه
وخلال فتره بسيطه صرت اجيد اللعبه صرت
افوز ببعض الدورات اللي كانت ينظمها
النادي فحسبت نفسي تايجر طبعا بالنسبه لنا
تاجر مثل ميسي ورونالدو في الكوره يعني
فحبيت اني ادخل المنتخب
المملكه فتواصلت مع رعايه الشباب
حاليا لكن في بعض الموظفين ارامكو يمثلونا
في بعض البطولات الخارجيه واعطوني رقمهم
وتواصلت معهم
للظهران الملعب وتفاجات بعمرين الامر
الاول
ما شاء الله كان مستواهم جدا عالي والشيء
ثاني
فانا متعود على ملعب عشب وتكرم يعني جزء
من الجولف فيها مسامير حديد
تسهل تثبيتك لما تضرب بالضربه
فهناك لازم تلبس جزمه يعني ما فيها مسامير
فما كان عندي جزمه ثانيه فاضطرت ان العب
حافي فاول يعني مباراه مع المنتخب كنت
هذا الموضوع
وتدرجت مع المنتخب السنين طويله
وبطلعت عربيه معاهم الحمد لله وسبحان الله
بعد توفيق الله كانت يعني احد اسباب دخولي
عالم النقل والخدمات تعطينا قصه الدخول
هذه انت تو قبل التصوير تقول لي على كيف
تغيرت هذه اللعبه من لعبه نخبويه لشريحه
معينه مجتمع الى لعبه ذات يعني
ممارسين اوسع وش اللي تغير
يمكن نقطه تتحول كانت بظهور تايجر يعني
صحيح طبعا هو جاي من يعني خلفيه يعني كانت
او الباقره كان ما هو يعني بطبقه
استقراطيه وكان يعني
صغير السن وكان رياضي
فغير المفهوم هذا وبعد يعني السنين بسيطه
من هذا طبعا
دخول تايجر هذا المجال جذب كثير من الشباب
لهذه اللعبه فتغيرت اليوم شوف افضل
اللاعبين بعمر العشرين والواحد وعشرين
يعني فتغيرت اللعبه
وكيف دخلت هذه اللعبه لعالم القطاع
اللوجستي اللي اشتغلت فيه انت في القطاع
البري والجوي والبحري
شاركت في بطوله اللي كانت منظمتها شركه
دي اتشال في البطولات تعرض استراتيجتها
للعملاء
وين مخططات وين يروحوا فعجبني بيئه العمل
ويحبون الجولف فقلت لازم اني اشتغل بهذه
الشركه وتقدمت لها والحمد لله وفقني ربي
وبديت معهم وبدات اول وظيفه معهم في مندوب
مبيعات منطقه الدمام
كنا ندور على الشركات ونحاول نبيع الخدمه
خدمه الخدمه خدمه
وبعدين لعب الرئيس لشؤون التجاريه
بعد انتقلت الى الجو الحمد لله مع الخطوط
السعوديه للشحن كان يستنفيذي في وقت كان
مليء بالتحديات انه كان مطلوب منا تحول
يعني تحول عمله تحول للشركه
وجدت في فتره كورونا فكان في اعتماد كبير
على الشحن الجوي الحمد لله يعني ربي
يوفقنا نكون في وقت نقدر نخدم في في بلدنا
والان الحمد لله ما في البحر في الهيئه
العمل المعالجه 2021 تقود هيئه الموانع
واللي هي جهاز ما يلامس كثير من من الناس
لانها علاقتها الاكبر مع الشركات مع
القطاعات العامه فخلينا نبدا ونعرف الناس
على موضوع الموانع بشكل عام بعدين ندخل
على هيئه مانا تحديدا وشو هذا الجهاز
بالضبط طيب
بدايات النقل البحري مر في طبعا رحلات
تطوير كثيره من بدايه من العصر الحجري
يعني يطور الانسان وقتها القوارب البدائيه
يعني من اغصان الشجر
لغرض الصيد اليوم وصلنا الى سفن العملاقه
سفن حياه تحمل اكثر من عشرين الف حاويه
وطوله يزيد عن 400 متر يعني تخيل طول
سفينه وحده تساوي اربعه ملاعب كره قدم
واجهه واحده من واجهات المكعب اللي في حي
المربع الجديد بما اننا متفاعلين
يعني لكن اهم يمكن نقطه تحول وسوى الثوره
في عالم النقل البحري كان في 1950 سنه
اخترع الحاويه
طبعا اختراع الحاويه يعني نقله نوعيه في
في طريقه النقل البحري سهلت على الموانع
بتوحيد توحيد الاجراءات التشغيليه في
الموانع
صرعت في عمليه المناوله
مما نتج بقله التكلفه طبعا زاد الطلب على
النقل البحري من وقت من وقتها وطبعا انا
اليوم جايكم الاستوديو اشوف برا ما شاء
الله حاويات
يعني
ذوقنا حلو طلع عشان الواجهه
الاستديو جميل الله يعطيك العافيه
فيعني
من بعد طبعا الاهتمام يعني او اهميه النقل
البحري بالنسبه للدول يعني هو عصب
بالاقتصاد ويعني شريان الحركه التجاريه
اليوم اكثر من 80% من كميه التبادل
التجاري انقل عن طريق البحر 80% نعم واكثر
من 70% من قيمه التبادل التجاري ينقل عن
طريق البحر احنا في المملكه اليوم
90% من صادراتنا سبعين في المئه من
الواردات تمر من خلال المعاناه
فلذلك يعني مهندس الرؤيه ولي العهد يعني
حدد ثلاث مكان من لقوه الرؤيه
بعد عربي واسلامي
وايضا قوه استثماريه رائعه
وموقع استراتيجي يربط القراءه الثلاثه
الحمد لله في ايمان تام ان القطاع النقل
وخدمات اللوجستيه قطاع ممكن رئيسي لجميع
القطاعات الاخرى لتحقيق مستهدفات الرؤيه
ولما نتكلم اليوم عن هيئه كم عدد الموظفين
كم عدد المواد التي تشرف عليها بس عشان
نفهم مشهد قم ما ندخل على حكايه التحول
طيب انا يمكن اعطيك رحله
لهيئه العمل معنا وكيف بدت
في اربع مراحل مرحله ما قبل 1976 كانت هي
اداره وليس جهاز منفصل كانت تحت وزاره
الماليه بعدين السكك الحديد وين حرس
الحدود وانتهت في وزاره
في السبعينات كان في تحدي ان اول شيء كان
في طفره عمرانيه وكان في طلب كبير على
مواد البناء والاسمنت ومختلف البضائع
لكنها ما كانت يعني بنت تحتي ما كانت
جاهزه لاستقبال للكمل الكبير من هذه
البضائع والسفن فكانت السفن تنتظر في
منطقه المخطاف اكثر من 6 اشهر لا يتم
مناولتها المناطق المقطوعه في منطقه
انتظار السفن خارج حدود الميناء تقريبا
عشره من البحري ويختلف من ميناء الى ميناء
فالدوله امرت بتسير يعني على اساس الصرف
تروح الى منطقه المقطاف تحمل البضائع
وتجيبها الى الميناء لكن هذا الحل ما كان
يعني مستدام فكان لازم يكون في حل جذري
وهذه المرحله الثانيه في 1976
صدر مرسوم ملكي بتاسيس المؤسسه العامه
للمعانة
واعطيت لها ميزانيات ضخمه لتوسع في
الموانع والانشاء موانع جديده وبدات
تتوالى المعاينه لما وصلنا اليوم الى الى
المرحله الثالثه وهي مرحله مهمه ايضا
مرحله دخول للموانع في عالم التخصيص في
طبعا قبل هذا التاريخ كانت الموانئ هي
اللي تشغل العمليات في الموانع لكن بعد
هذا التاريخ اسندت تشغيل على القطاع الخاص
فاصبح ان اشغل الارصفه المعاينه والمحطات
المعونه لزياده الكفاءه التشغيليه في
المرحله الرابعه
وهي مرحله الرؤيه في 2018 بعد تحولنا الى
هيئه اصبحت هيئه عمل الموانع لها تنظيم
المستقل لها استقلاليه ماليه وتعمل على
اسس تجاريه ولها مجلس اداره يعني يسير
امور الهيئه على اساس يسهل تعامل التجاري
مع القطاع الخاص ويسهل مهمتها في تحقيق
مستهدفات الرؤيه
وانت تبون 13 مينا كم منها تبعكم فاحنا
نشرف اليوم على عشر موال
وفي ثلاثه خارج اشرافكم
في ميناء الملك عبد الله ميناء جيزان
للصلاه الاساسيه
الان سلم الى نيوم لتشغيل العام من ضمن
طبعا مشروع
هنا لفت نظري يعني شيء غريب انه انتم
الهيئه المنظمه وفي ثلاث موانع ما هي تحت
اشرافكم يعني لو بنشبهها مثلا بالطيران
المدني هيئه المدني تشرف على كل المطارات
السعوديه حتى اللي ما تملكها يعني حتى
مثلا مطار البحر الاحمر تحت اطار مدنيه
مطار المدينه المنوره لبنان القطاع الخاص
تحت الطائره مدنيه في حالتكم انتم في مانع
خارج
اشرافكم ليش موجود
لها مثلا
يعني صفه اقتصاديه اليوم ميناء جيزان
لصلاه الاساسيه وفي مدينه جزاء للصلاه
الاساسيه وتحت الهيئه الملكيه للجبال
وينبع ف
اتفاقيات على اساس التنظيم الدولي اللي
تابعه لمنظمه
منظمه دوري البحريه فنحن في اتفاقيه بيننا
وبينهم فيكون في تنسيق
بين المناعين وايضا الموان الاخرى من
الملك عبدالله ومن الضبع
الاهم من ذلك ان كل هذه المعونه سواء كانت
تحت اشراف الهيئه او تحت اشراف جهه اخرى
انها تتبع الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه لتحقيق المستندات من
طاقات استيعابيه من كفاءه التشغيليه او
خلاف
ونتكلم احنا على الهيئه احنا نتكلم على او
على الميناء نفسه نتكلم على مين اللاعبين
في الميناء نفسه يعني خلينا ناخذ مثلا
اكبر ميناء انتم ميناء جده صح والثاني
واحد بنعملك عبد العزيز في الدمام خليني
اعطيك تحب فكره على
13 ميناء طبعا ما شاء الله السواحل في
المملكه كبيره
3400 كيلو
على البحر الاحمر اكبر ميناء ميناء جده
الاسلامي اكبر ميناء في المملكه واكبر
ميناء على البحر الاحمر من متكامل في كل
انواع البضائع وكيف تقيس حجمه بعدد
الحاويات بعد الحاويات وعدد الطنيات فاحنا
كيف نقول اكبر ميلاد على البحر الاحمر
اليوم يناول 5 مليون حاويه
تقريبا 60 مليون طن في السنه فمن متكامل
وفي جميع انواع البضائع في موانع متخصصه
للحاويات في موانا متخصص البضاء العامه
جدا منها محوري يناول جميع انواع البضائع
حلو عندك منبع تجاري وينض الصناعي ميناء
ضباء وميناء جزاء للصناعات الاساسيه ومن
جازان التجاري هذا البحر الاحمر الخليج
العربي اكبر ميناء في المملكه على الخليج
العربي من الملك عبد العزيز بن ايضا ميناء
متكامل ومحوري هنا من اكبر المواقع
النفطيه في العالم
ميناء الجبيل الصناعي من اكبر موانع
البتروكي في العالم وميناء التجاري وايضا
ميناء ميناء راس الخير وميناء الخفجي
بعضهم وانا متخصصه
الاكبر في جده ثاني واحد في الدمام
ميناء الملك عبد الله اللي في رابط هذا وش
يصنف عبد الله الان طبعا هو من اكبر
الامانه المحوريه لشحنات المسافنه او
لحاويات المسافه ترانزيت طبعا بعد اكتمال
العمل فيه والتوسعات حيكون من محوري
متكامل ايضا وهيخدم نفس رؤيه
استراتيجيه الوطنيه النقل وخدمات لانه هو
من احد ركائز اليوم اليوم هو يعني اكبر
ثاني اكبر ميناء من ناحيه حاجات المسافره
نعم حياه مسافره تحديدا مش الحاويات طيب
لو نشرح شوي موضوع مفهوم المسافنه او
الترانزيت ممتاز طبعا يمكن اقرب مثال في
المطارات طبعا هي تيجي الحاويه مثلا من
الصين تبغى تروح الى اوروبا لكن توقف مثلا
في ميناء جده الاسلامي
ما تدخل البلد تنزل من عند ظهر السفينه
وبعدين تطلع في السفينه اخرى وتكمل
مشوارها الى اوروبا طبعا اهميتها كبيره
المسافه اقتصاديا للبلد
تجذب سفن ملاحيه اكثر
تعطي خيارات اكثر للمستوردين والمصدرين
يكون في مساحات اضافيه على السفن ومنها
يقل التكلفه وايضا تخلق مجمع او ايكو
سيستم
حول الموانع يعني من مناطق لوجستيه مناطق
حره مناطق اعاده التصدير وايضا مصانع مثلا
التغليف
وخلافه
واخر حكايه التحول ابغى افهم الميناء
نفسها من الاطراف اللي تلعب فيه انتم
الجمارك المشغل دور كل واحد طبعا الحمد
لله اليوم في تكامل كبير بين بيننا وبين
شركائنا في في المعنى اليوم يعني في اكثر
من 13 جهه تعمل بالموانع
عندك طبعا من اهمهم هيئه الزكاه الجمارك
مسؤوله عن طبعا التخليص الجمركي وامن
البضائع حرس الحدود يقوم بتامين حدود
الميناء
هيئه الغذاء والدواء ناحيه المواصفات
والمقاييس وزاره الزراعه وكثير من شركائنا
من القطاعات الحكوميه عم يعملوا في
الموانع يمكن اذا بتحب اعطيك يعني رحله
مثلا الصادر او الوارد يمكن
نقرب
دوركم انتم ودور المشغل لانه
اشحنها تشكل على بعض الناس انه انتم انتم
تملكون ولا تشغلون طيب بشغلة وشدوده الى
اخره ومن بعد
الخصصين ويعني مشاركه القطاع الخاص
ولا تشغلها اليوم التشغيل من القطاع الخاص
نعم نحن اليوم دورنا اشرافي على المشغلين
اليوم جذب استثمارات اكبر في الموانع
تحسين البنات تحتيه في مناطق المسانده
تحسين ايضا الاعماق في قنوات الاقتراب وفي
مناطق المختار عندنا دور استثماري ايضا
حكوميه ونحن نمكن يعني يمكن اختصرها في
كلمات دورنا تمكين
قطاعات الاخرى من من يعني من النمو
والنجاح مثل قطع الصناعي يعني التصدير
اليوم 90% من التصدير تمر من خلال
المعاناه فاذا ناخذ مثلا رحله
الواردات اذا تحب طبعا
توصل السفينه الى منطقه المخطاف هي منطقه
الانتظار
تطلب اذن الدخول الميلان مثل الطيارات
يعني اليوم الطياره ما تنزل اي مطار لما
تاخذ اذن الهبوط
تاخذ اذن من برج المراقبه يتم ارسالها
مرشدين مع قطرات لانه ما في سفينه تدخل اي
مينا لما يكون فيها مرشدين لان فيها قنوات
اقتراب دقيقه او لازم يعني تحكم بشكل دقيق
فتبدا عمليات الارشاد وبعدين عمليات
الترصيف في في محطه الحاويات بعدين يتم
مناوله الحاويات من عن ظهر السفينه الى
ارض الميناء يتم التخليص الجمركي واذا
كانت مثلا البضاعه تحتاج عمليات اضافيه في
مناطق لوجستيه يتم عمل هذه
العمليات الاضافيه او بتطلع مباشره الى
السوق بشكل مباشر يعني اليوم الحمد لله ما
يعني الاصلاحات
التشريعيه والتنظيميه وايضا اعاده هندسه
الاجراءات ايضا مع شركائنا من هيئه الزكاه
والضيق الجمارك يعني في 2016 كانت تاخذ
الحاويه اكثر من 14 يوم
لما تفتح وتطلع من الميناء اليوم نتكلم عن
ثمان ساعات
والمستهدف الوصول الى ساعتين اليوم هي
تتذكر الجمارك اعنت على مبادره فصح خلال
ساعتين
ففيت في يعني الحمد لله تقدم كبير في في
هذا
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
بدات في حكايه التحول خلينا نكمل ونقول
ايش اليوم تغير في هذا القطاع في هذا
المجال
وخليني ابدا باكثر تساؤل موجود في اذهان
الناس احنا تذكرت على مزايا
[موسيقى]
عاليه جدا السعوديه تمتاز فيها من حيث
المساحه وجودها على
واجهتين بحريه الاطوال عدد الموانئ
ورغم كل ذلك
ميناء واحد في دبي اكبر من شغل كل مانع
السعوديه او شيء هل هذه المعلومه الصحيحه
وثانيا ليش احنا ما اخذنا هذا الموقع اللي
يتناسب مع حجمنا وحجم
الاقتصاد والحركه التجاريه قاعد تصير في
السعوديه
جاوب على السؤال
مقارنه هذا بس يمكن حنا ابدا في يعني كيف
اطلقت الاستراتيجيه يعني احنا الحمد لله
اليوم كقيادات حكوميه محظوظين عندنا رؤيه
واضحه عندنا استراتيجيه تحكم التنفيذ
عندنا اليوم تناغم بين شركائنا بالجهات
الحكوميه والقطاع الخاص عندنا اليوم مصادر
تمويليه من برامج الرؤيه انقطاع الخاص
يعني شريك
واهم ذلك عندنا شباب وشبات الوطن مؤمنين
به ذه الرؤيه
وطموحين بتنفيذها سمو العهد جزاه الله خير
اعطانا كل ممكنات نجاح على طبق من ذهب
وقال انطلقوا فما عندنا عذر
اليوم يعني بعد اطلاق الرؤيه واطلاق
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل وخدمات
اللوجستيه
اطلقت بمباركه سمو سيدي في منتصف عام 2021
فمعالي الوزير صالح الجاسر حرس ان يكون في
حوكمه واضحه لتنفيذ تنبثق من هذه
الاستراتيجيه ست استراتيجيات قطاعيه
صيدليه الطيران
البحري استراتيجيه
الطرق استراتيجيه
البري والسرديه الخدمات
هذه الاستراتيجيات محفظتها اكثر من 750
مشروع ورصد لها اكثر من تريليون و300
مليار ريال لتنفيذ هذه المشاريع من التمول
من البرامج من القطاع الخاص ومن الصندوق
طبعا انك تطلع باستراتيجيه صعب لكن الان
عمليه التنفيذ
فلازم كان الحوكمه يكون لها دور فعال
ويكون يكون اشراف معالي الوزير على هذه
الاستراتيجيات بشكل بشكل كبير يعني ما
عليها الله يجزاه الخير يجتمع مع كل
منظومه لوحدها مره في الشهر اجينا في
الهيئه مثلا
مع فريق عملي يتابع مسار تنفيذ هذه
المشاريع المستحدثات وايضا نجتمع معنا
كمنظومه واحده مره في الشهر
كان بالنسبه لي وفريق عملي من المهم ان
يكون عندي خطه واضحه اقدر فيها اعرضها
للوزير ونقدر نستهدف فيها
هذه المؤشرات
ايش سوينا طبعا جلسنا مع جميع المستفيدين
عرضنا لهم الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه هذا اللي نبغى نوصل له
جلسنا اول شيء مع موظفينا
لفينا على كل الموانع عرضنا الاستراتيجيه
المصدرين مع الغرف التجاريه مع شركات
الملاحيه جميع المستفيدين
واخذنا التحديات اللي شايفينها بتحقيق هذه
المستحدفات واخذنا ايضا الفرص اللي موجوده
اللي نحن ممكن نكون شايفينها وغير شيء مو
شايفينها
فرسمنا رحله المستفيدين بالكامل وحددنا
مواطن الضعف اللي فيها وحدنا ايضا
ايش الفرص اللي موجوده وطلعنا في 160
مشروع
هذا 160 مشروع رصد لها اكثر من 40 مليار
ريال ايضا من من البرامج ومن برامج الرؤيه
ومن القطاع الخاص
يمكن طلعنا في يمكن يوم اتكلم يمكن على
خمس من اهم المشاريع لها اثر ايجابي على
يعني مدى يعني مدى تحقيقنا لهذه الرؤيه
القدره التنافسيه التنافسيه للمعال
يعني نحن يمكن ارجع يمكن لسؤالك انه بعض
الموانع المجاوره افضل افضل من
صحيحه بشكل كامل المعلومه
الظاهر 20 مليون ولا كم سعته اليوم يناول
تقريبا من 15 الى 18 مليون عنده كل مانع
السعوديه كم اليوم
يعني ما هو واحد 15 وانتو كل 11 ممتاز
طبعا يعني
خلينا ناخذ الموانئها فقط حاويات عندك
اداره حاويات وعندك اداره بضاعه اخرى
بضاعه سائبه بضائع عامة بضائع
فلازم تاخذ انت الميناء بمجمل
نيجي للحاويات يمكن في الماضي الفرس لكن
بعض بعد صدور الرؤيه وصدور الاستراتيجيه
الوطنيه للناقل وخدمات اللوجستيه اليوم مع
الطموحنا عشره ولا 15 ولا 20 مليون
والحمد لله خلال اربع سنوات الماضيه شفنا
تسارع ونمو في عدا اعداد الحاويات يعني
كانت في الحصه السوقيه
لحاويات المسافره في 2018
كنا 18%
اليوم في نهايه 2020 وصلنا الى واحد
وثلاثين.3% خمسه مليون حاله خمسه مليون
ونصف
الى
45% حصه السوقيه ما يعادل 16 مليون حاويه
هذه فقط مسافره
اليوم مدى ربطنا بالموانه هذا مؤشر ايضا
مهم وقاص عالميا في تقرير الامم المتحده
يقيس مدى ربط الموانئ في الدوله الفلانيه
الاخرى احنا في 2016 كنا في النقطه 52
اليوم اصبحنا في النقطه
71.1 الفرق بينه وبين اعلى منطقه اعلى
دوله في المنطقه ثلاث نقاط فقط هذه الدرجه
من ميه نعم هي معادله تحسب لك النقاط يعني
مثلا اعلى دوله يا الصين 170 نقطه
هذه على الدوله اعلى دوله في المنطقه اللي
هي الامارات افترض 73 74 74 احنا اليوم
كنا 51 كنا 52
هذا المقصود فيه عدد الرحلات المجدوله
نحن المسافرين
الرحلات المجدوله بين ميناء الف وبناء باء
اكثر من من
نقطه تاخذ عدد السفن التي تزور الموانع
السعوديه مثلا ناخذ موان السعوديه
حجم هذه السفن يعني ممكن تجيك سفن كثيره
لكن حجمها قليل فما ما تعطيك طاقات
الاستعابيه
فهذه اهم النقطتين تحسب في هذا المؤشر
فنحن مستهدفنا في عشرين ثلاثين وصول الى
80 نقطه في اكبر عشر دول في العالم
وهذا لها تاثير مباشر على التكلفه هذا
المؤشر بالذات
يعني تاثير مباشر على تكلفه النقل يعني
اذا كل ما زاد ارتباطك ارتباطك في
بالمعنى الاخرى قله التكلفه اليوم الحمد
لله نرتبط مباشره ب 113 ميناء مباشره 250
ميناء
بطريقه غير مباشره اذا جيت حسبت
حجم الميناء بشكل الكامل نحن اليوم
بالاطنان طبعا لكن يمكن اللي موجود او في
التقرير الدولي تعتمد اكثر الحاويات لانه
نرجع نقول ان الحاويات تسهلت الامور على
العالم لان شهر قياس اما الاطنان مثلا مثل
المواد بتروليه ولا مواد بتروكوميه موجوده
حسب لكن كل الموانع تنشر هذه هذه الارقام
فدائما التقرير الدوليه تحسب
الحاويات
لكن اجمالي مثلا المهن السعودي اجمالي ما
تناوله في السنه 680 مليون طن
اكبر من الموانع اكبر من بعض الموانع
المحوريه في العالم اكبر من سنغافوره اكبر
من هولندا واكبر من الامارات
لكن حلو انه يكون في المنطقه وصحي يكون في
تنافس يعني هم افضل منا في بعض الامور
المنافسين ونحن عندنا يعني امور نحن افضل
منها لكن الحمد لله بالطموحات الموجوده ان
شاء الله في 2030 هنكون باذن الله الاكبر
في المنطقه ونكون المنصه اللوجستيه
الاكبر في المنطقه ولو بنتكلم احنا على
موضوع نفس الشيء موضوع سهوله
وجاذبيه الموانع السعوديه دائما يذكر
موضوع البث البضائع اللي جايتنا من اوروبا
ولا جايتنا من افريقيا تعبر شفت المانع
الخمسه اللي سردتهم في البحر الاحمر
تتعديهم كلهم
وتاخذ الرسك العبور باكثر نقطه خطره في
العالم اظن هذه بالارقام هي اكثر تخاطره
من حيث القراصنه اللي هي مضيق باب المندب
تعدي هذا الخطر وتمر ببحر العرب ثم تدخل
الخليج وتنزل في جبل علي
وتنزل بضائع هناك ثم تشحنها لك بريا الى
الرياض وجده وبقيت المملكه وش اللي كان
يدفع
المشغلين واللي يشحنون انه ياخذون كل
هالمسافه الطويله وهذا الرزق المضاعف ولا
يستخدمون بهالدرجه كانت مؤنثه سيئه شوفي
يمكن
كان في تحديات بالفصحى الجمركي وتحديات
ايضا بالتشغيل في الموانع لكن مع الرؤيه
ومع الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه لنقل الخدمات
اللوجستيه كثير من هذه الامور الان اتحلت
انا اليوم الفتح وصل الى ثمان ايام فانا
كتاجر عفوا ثمان
كم كان 14 يوم نبغى نوصل الى ثمان ساعات
المستهدف ساعتين ان شاء الله
انا كتاجر اليوم ليش ابغى ان اطول عليه
الطريق وازيد عليه التكلفه اذا اقدر انا
اجيبها للمكان انا احتاجه فاليوم يعني
نتكلم بشكل ما تعاون جميع الجهات الحكوميه
يوم اقل من اثنين في المئه من اجمالي ما
يدخل المملكه يجي عن طريق يعني
اقل من اثنين في المئه
فاليوم الحمد لله نرجع نقول اليوم الموان
السعوديه من اكثر الموانع كفاءه في العالم
صدرنا التقارير الدوليه اليوم تقرير البنك
الدولي السعوديه الاكثر كفاءه في مناوه
الحاويات ميناء الملك عبد الله رقم واحد
في العالم
ميناء جده
تقدم من مرتبه 53 الى المرتبه الثامنه في
عام واحد
من الملك عبد العزيز بالدمام تقدم المرتبه
102 الى المرتبه
المرتبه الرابعه عشر ايضا خلال عام واحد
من 370 ميناء حول العالم فاليوم يعني
الشركه شركه الملاحه البحريه لما تيجي
تبقى تزور مينا عندها اربع امور لازم تفكر
فيها
كفاءه الاوشه كفاءه التشغيل الموانع
التكلفه
الطلب يعني هل في سوق يعني كبير في هذا في
هذه الموانع والخدمات الاضافيه اللي
محتاجينها فالحمد لله كفاءه اليوم نحن من
افضل الموانئ العالميه التكلفه اليوم
تكلفه الموانع مشكله كانت يعني هي واحده
من النقاط اللي اثرت على ترتيبنا في مؤشر
اقل من 40% من المنافسين اليوم تكلفه اجور
الموانئ
استيراد وتصدير بشكل بشكل عالي في مشاريع
كبرى اليوم في المملكه يمكن النقط الرابع
الان نحن نعمل عليها بشكل متسارع اللي هي
ايجاد يعني خدمات اضافيه لا نعمل على
انشاء مراكز متكامله في الموانع في عام
2022 نجحنا بتوقيع الثمن عقود لانشاء
مراكز متكامله مع اكبر الشركات يعني اكبر
الشركات الشحن في العالم
مستثمرين في الموانع السعوديه ايضا
الشركات الوطنيه
البحري جلوبمرين استثمروا في مناطق
الجنسيه المتكامله هنتخيل مثلا هذا
بالنسبه لمارسك المركز اللوجي اللي في
ميناء جده الاسلامي
اعلى استثمار لهم في العالم
بمنطقه واحده بالمنطقه لوجستيه تذكر حلقه
قبل شهرين مع
خالد البواردي مستثمر القطاع اللوجستي
ومهتم بهذا الموضوع كان وهو موجود في
الامارات ايضا كان يقول تكلفه المساحه
اللوجستيه في هو وهو كان في الامارات برضه
يمكن ثلث تكلفه
الاستئجار لمساحه لوجستيه في السعوديه
نتكلم على الاراضي
على الرسوم الاراضي اليوم عندنا لائحه وفي
اسعار مختلفه يعني حسب طبعا الارض اللي في
الميناء الارض ما هي مثل الاراضي اللي
موجوده مثلا في مناطق
لوجستي او مستودعات داخل البلد لانها على
قرب البحر يعني لها افضليه
لكن عندنا اسعار متفاوته يعني القريبه من
الرصيف تكون اغلى اذا كانت ابعد من الرصيف
لكن طبعا عندنا اليوم مجلس اداره او يعني
عند الصلاحيه انه يتحكم في لاحد فلاحه
التاجير
نحن اذا كان في بزنس كيس واضحه احنا اليوم
يعني هدفنا مو الايرادات من الاجارات
الاراضي هذه نحن ما عملنا بعقارين طبعا
مكن الميناء اليوم نبغى نمكن نمينا من
النمو يكون في خدمات على مستوى عالمي لكن
اجتنا كثير من المناطق اللوجستيه كان بزنس
كيس واضح
يوضح الاثر الايجابي على المواعنه من
الزيادات في اعداد الحاويات واعداد
الكميات
وتقديم خدمات غير مسبوقه في المعانة واخذت
اسرار منافسه جدا فاليوم اي احد عنده
اليوم فكره لانشاء مراكز او مصانع تفيد
الميناء يعني
نحن اليوم
نشوف هذه الطلبات ونقدر نحن نتعامل معها
من الاشياء التي تنظري في مستهدفاتكم رفع
نسبه التشغيل الى 95 99 رفع نسبه التشغيل
الى 70% من طاقه المواله احنا اليوم كم
طاقه الموانع وكم كم نسبه التشغيل حاليا
وما تقدر توصل يعني
لازم تعطي نفسك مجال
لان هي سلسله او رحله انا الحاويه تنزل من
السفينه الى ارض الميناء فاذا كانت نسبه
الاجراميه في المئه وين بتروح
بس بالعكس في العالم 70% هو هذا الرقم
اللي اغلب الموان العالميه تشتغل عليها
احنا اليوم 60
موضوع تشغيل الموانئ هذا بدينا فيه بس ما
كملناه ودي اعرف اليوم لما نقول تخصيص
الموانع هل معناته انه في قطاع خاص يملك
هذه الموانع ولا فقط يشغلها ايش معنا
تشغلها ومنهم هذول المشغلين لا طبعا نحن
منشات سياديه فيعني املاك الحكومه القطاع
الخاص
في عندنا يعني خطوات الان نعمل عليها لفصل
الجانب التشريعي عن الجانب التشغيلي
القطاع الخاص اليوم بين عقود اسنادس لقطاع
الخاص يعني مسؤوليته نشغل هذه المحطات
ويستثمر في توسعتها وجلب افضل التقنيات
وبعد انتهاء هذا العقد 30 سنه ترجع ملكيه
هذه المحطه الى او يعني كل ما تم استثماره
من معدات الى نظام البيوتي نعم وهذا
المشغل هو اللي يدير عمليه تفريغ الحاويات
واداره السفن وارشادها والى اخرها هذا دور
المشغل نعم اكثر من مشغل طبعا
خلينا ناخذ مثلا نفصلها محطه الحاويات لها
مشغل الارشاد البحري والعمليات البحريه
لها مشاكل اخر المناطق اللوجستيه لها ايضا
مشغلين في تنوع بالمشغلين في المعالجه بس
ما في مشغل الرئيسي هو اللي قاعد اه اوكي
اتذكر الاسئله اللي هنا
وسط من احد الاصدقاء كان سؤال على من
سميتهم منافسين
كيف نعطي تشغيل موانئنا للمنافسين بكل ما
في ذلك من تعارض مصالح ومخاطر وتحديات ايش
رايك يقصد فيها طبعا شركه مانو دبي اللي
اخذت عقد التشغيل اكبر منها في السعوديه
من جده صح يشغل احد المحطات في ميناء جده
وهو احد من 11 مشغل في منع جده طبعا في
محطتين رئيسيتين في ميناء جده محطه
الجنوبيه للحاويات يشغلها اموال دبي واحط
الشماليه نشغلها بوابه البحر الاحمر شركه
وطنيه ويملك فيها صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه حصه منها وان شاء الله لا طبعا
لاحظ طبعا خطط العام التوسع في خارج
المملكه وتشغيل موانع خارج المملكه
موانع دبي شريك قديم معانا في في ميناء
جدا من 97 هو موجود وعامل معنا على تطوير
المحطه الجنوبيه وزياده الكميات
دبي عنده شبكه عالميه من المعاناه في 60
ميناء حول العالم وهذا كان من اهم الاسباب
انه يكون موجود في من اجل الجلب هذه
الحركه الموجوده طبعا عندها عقود مع شركات
الملاحيه
الكبيره فهذا هذا العمل راح يجي الى ميناء
جده فما في تعرض وبينها وبينهم في يعني
اتخيل في ذهن السائل انه هو هم بالنسبه
لهم كل ما يعني ضعفت موانعنا زادت فرسهم
بهذا الشكل البسيط احنا قطعنا الامارات
جار وشقيق وعزيز فانا ما اتكلم عن نواحي
السياسيه اتكلم عن النواحي التجاريه بحته
انه انت تدير ميناء
وكلفت باداره الميناء المنافس يعني
البديهيا انا ما هو من مصلحته انه هذا
الميناء يكبر وينجح وياخذ حركه تجاريه
كبيره لانه حتكون على حسابي يعني
دبي عندها استثمارات ضخمه في منها جده
اليوم اكثر من 4 مليار ريال وبينه وبينه
موقود اسناد فيها مؤشرات واضحه على كميات
المناوله المطلوبه منهم يعني بشكل تجاري
ما يقدر يعني اي مشغلة كانه في العالم
بكميه هذه الاستثمارات الموجوده بالعقود
الموجوده هذه انه يعني ما ينجح والحمد لله
قسم نجاح طويله من 97 وفي نمو سنه عن سنه
وفي
الاعداد الحاويات كانت تنمو سلام سنه مع
شركائنا جميعا الحمد لله
اتذكر لما كنا نشتغل على برنامج سين كنت
انا مع ابو يوسف احمد الشقيري
ووحده من الحلقات كانت عن الموانئ
وراح صور يعني في واحد من
الرافعات اللي كانت اعتقد عن بعد او تدار
من غرفه مستقله او لو تحاكيني عن وش
التطور اللي صار في البنيه التحتيه او في
ميكنه او اتمته اجراءات الموانع طبعا نحن
عندنا طبعا مشروع كبير
مسمين التحول الى موانع ذكيه او الموانع
الذكيه طبعا يعني اكيد المملكه من الدول
السباقه في التحول الرقمي في الحكومه
ويعني يمكن نحن طبعا كما انا الان بدينا
في عمليه التحول ولكن عالميا يمكن الموانئ
بشكل عام يعني متاخر شوي على عمليه التحول
الرقمي بشكل كامل
[موسيقى]
منها جميع المستفيدين في المعاناه بالنسبه
للتشغيل
بدانا الان في حدود الميناء يعني اليوم ما
في شاحنه تدخل عند موعد الالكتروني
الحركه بشكل بشكل كبير اول يعني في الصعبه
كان في تكدسات مثلا على دخول المينا اليوم
ما في اي تكادس معدل دوران الشاحنه اليوم
وصل الى 19 دقيقه في السابق كان ست ساعات
19 من وصولها
19 دقيقه واو وهذا تنزل حاويه يمديها تنزل
الحاويه 19 دقيقه
وهذا اعطى
القابليه لشركات نقلات نستخدم شاحنه اكثر
من مره في اليوم تاخذ ست ساعات
المرحله الثانيه البوابات نفسها الان تكون
ذكيه يعني توصل الشاحنه بالموعد
الالكتروني البوابه تقرا لوحه الشاحنه
وتقرا وجه السائق
وطابقه في النظام اذا كل المعلومات صحيحه
تفتح الباب بوابه وتدخل ان شاء الله اول
بوابه حتكون في منتصف من العام هذا
الصيف هذه السنه ان شاء الله ما شاء الله
الطبق على جميع الموانع تدريجيا لكن الاهم
من ذلك هو تشغيل نفسها في الموانع اللي هو
في المحطات اليوم ذكرتها
نحن كل الرافعات في موانئنا لتتم مناوره
فيها الحاويات تكون معتمته وتعمل عن بعد
اليوم الرافعه الرافعات الموجوده تعمل
بشكل يدوي يعني مشغل بيطلع في مقصوره في
نفس الرافعه ويتم مناوله الحاويات اليوم
الكفاءه تقريبا من 27 الى 30 حاويه في
الساعه
الان وصلنا 12 حاويه من التقنيه الجديده
لها فوائد كثيره اول شيء
12 رافعه نعم
لها فوائد كثيره اول فائده طبعا حتكون
تشغيلها من غرف تحكم في مقرات المشغلين
الرئيسيه فهتخلط بئه عمل اليوم جاذب اكثر
لشباب وشابات الوطن
ثانيا زياده كفاءه التشغيليه من 27 حتوصل
الى 36 37 حاويه في الساعه
ايضا
تفيد البيئه لان هذه كل المعدات تشتغل
بالكهرباء المعدات القديمه تشتغل في
الديزل فهتقلل البعثات الكربونيه فلا
فوائد كثيره ايضا الشحنات اللي اللي تعمل
في ساحه المحطه حتكون ذاتيه القياده فان
شاء الله المستهدف ان المحطه الحاويات ما
حيكون فيها تدخل بشري هذا ان شاء الله
بحلول عام 20 25
على صعيد موضوع الموارد البشريه يعني يمكن
من اهم تحولات
الهيئه هي قدرتها على
يعني اصدار سلالم خاصه فيها
وحوافز
نتيجه استقلالها المالي والاداري يعني انا
ما اعرفك ابو طلال صراحه الا من هالحلقه
تعرفت عليك من هذه الحلقه فما عندي فما
عندي اي دوافع ولا مصلحه اني اقول شيء ما
هو حقيقي لكن فعلا لفت نظري لما زرتكم في
المكتب خلصت اجتماعي معك مشيت بغادر مسكني
رجل الامن المدني السكيوريتي عند الباب
قال عرفني قال انت ثمانيه قلت هي حنا
ثمانيه قال متى حلقه المعالي ويسميك معالي
قلت له قريب ان شاء الله عندك ملاحظات في
شكوى وقل لي شيء قال لا والله ودي انك
تقول له شكرا لانه من 2018 حنا تحولنا الى
هيئه نسمع بالحوافز نسمع بالسلالم نسمع
ولا شف
بقدوم هذا الرجل فعلا تسارعت وتيره
التسكين
والتحسين في الحوافز والمزايا اللي كنا
نسمع عنها من 2018 فهذه الرساله انقلها
صراحه امانه منه لك ومنها ابغى اسمع ايش
اللي صار كتغير مؤسسه داخل الهيئه وداخل
قدرتها على استقطاب الكفاءات
للقياده المرحله القادمه يعني طبعا شكرا
على هذا الكلام بس طبعا يعني هذا واجبي
يعني طبعا وانا نفذت قرار مجلس الوزراء
يعني
لكن يمكن نحن صرنا في عمليه التنفيذ
يعني حكمنا الموضوع بطريقه انه نحن عرضناه
على مجلس الاداره بشكل واضح
وكان في دعم كبير من مجلس الاداره
بالموافقه على برنامج التسكين بناء على
قرار مجلس الوزراء والحمد لله بدانا في
عمليه التسكين في شهر تسعه من العام
الماضي عندنا 2800 موظف وهذا كان جزء اصلا
من الاستراتيجيه المؤسسيه
برحله التحول لتحويل الكوادر البشريه من
نظام الخدمه المدنيه نظام التامينات
الاجتماعيه
تمهيدا يعني مؤسسه الموانع وانشاء شركه
الموانع
الحمد لله تمت بكل ثلاثه كان
الحدث الرئيسي ان نحن نتواصل بشكل شفاف
عملنا ورشات عمل قبل ما نطلق
المشروع يعني وينفذ كان في سفراء للتسكين
في كل الموانع عملنا خط ساخن لاي
استفسارات
ونشرنا
الوثيقه السكين على البوابه الداخليه فانا
كان المهم ان الجميع يعرف ايش اللي جايب
يوم
الحمد لله مرت بسلاسه وايضا اللي كان مثلا
اخذ حقك كان في لجنه
لجنه تظلمات خارجيه اعتمدها مجلس الاداره
نظرت في هذا الامور كانت تقريبا اقل من
10% من اجمالي الموظفين والحمد لله يعني
اقفلنا مشروع التشكين في نهايه ديسمبر
الماضي واليوم انا اللي فهمت ان القطاع
ككل فيه حدود 11 الف
كم نسبه التوطين فيها وش بتسوون في تاهيل
تدريب كوادر بحيث انه هذه نسبه تزيد
بالذات في المواقع الحساسه
بشغل رافعه الى اخره من المهام احنا عندنا
ميه في المئه نسبه الشعوذه في المنظومه
بشكل كامل 40 في المئه تقريبا اليوم
ثمانيه في المئه من الوظائف ووظائف
تشغيليه من ساعتين شاحنات
عماله شحن وتفريغ هنا يجد دور التحول
الذكيه يعني اتمتت الاجراءات وعماله
التشغيليه وهذا المعدات الحديثه الان اللي
اللي
استثمر فيها المشغلين هتخلق وظائف جاذبه
وايضا علاقاتنا مع
الاكاديميات والجماعه اليوم الحمد لله
عندنا
اتفاقيه وعلاقه مع جامعه الملك عبد العزيز
وخمسين متخرج
في السنه طبعا نعمل على زياده هذا العدد
وايضا الان الاكاديميه اللوجستيه اللي
اطلقتها وزاره النقل والخدمات ايضا فيها
فيها طبعا مواد مختصه في الموانع
فنعمل نحن بعده مبادرات لزياده هذا النسبه
بنتقل لمجموعه من اسئله الاصدقاء والطلال
وحده من الاسئله جتنا هي موضوع
استراتيجيات قطاعيه تحت استراتيجيه النقل
الجزئيه
الموانع وش السبب اليوم الموانئ يجوز من
استراتيجيه القطاع البحري طبعا القطاع
البحري يعني كبير وفي يعني عده جهات اليوم
تعمل فيه ونحن اليوم الموانع جزء من هذه
الاستراتيجيات القطاع البحري التي يجوز من
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل والخدمات من
يقودها طبعا يقود الملف اليوم اعتماد
استراتيجيه اللي هي الهيئه العامه للنقل
المعهد الدكتور ماهر
هنا في سؤال على موضوع تشغيل رحلات الكروز
انتم كان لكم دور في موضوع تشغيل رحلات
الكروز اللي ابتدات في 2020 في السعوديه
وقاعده تتوسع شوي شوي فبدي اعرف بشكل عام
زائد هذا يسال تحديدا عن تشغيل ريحات كروز
من ميناء الدمام لان هذه الظاهر لسه ما
اشتغلت اشتغلت الموسم هذا الحمد لله طبعا
يعني
من دون انك تمكين قطاعه الاخرى يعني وكان
من ضمن استراتيجيه السياحه اطلاق رحلات
الكروز طبعا في العالم الكرز ممكن يكون
داخل الميناء ممكن يكون خارج الميناء لكن
احنا بسبب سرعه اطلاق هذه طبعا
هذه السفن وتزور موانع السعوديه بشكل سريع
يعني اختراع تكون موجوده بشراكه طبعا مع
شركه
انها تكون في الموانع كمرحله الاولى لانه
في البنت احتياج جاهزه الاعماق طبعا ما
شاء الله يعني السفن عملاقه مدينه متحركه
ما شاء الله تاخذ اكثر من 6000 مسافر في
وقت واحد
فالاعماقة مناسبه
وطورنا مع شركائنا في محطات الركاب بشكل
يعني مناسب لهذه السفن بدات طبعا اول موسم
نحن الان في الموسم الثالث الحمد لله يعني
يسافر تقريبا اكثر من ربع مليون مسافر 250
الف
بدات في اول سنه في رحلات اقليميه بين
السعوديه ومصر والاردن الموسم هذا نشوف
الان السياح يجونا من اوروبا
وايضا اليوم المواطن المواطن يقدر يطلع
بالكروز يوصل لبرشلونه
اليوم سوف نذكر استخدم في ميناء جده
الاسلامي موجوده في ميناء الملك عبد الله
موجوده في منع ينبع التجاري
وموجوده في ميناء الملك عبد العزيز
بالدمام مش اكثر وجهه لاحظت مرغوبه من
الكروز والله جدا جدا
وتمشي على طول يعني
ممكن
تقضي يومك في هذا القريه التاريخيه وترجع
الى الكروس فكان لها يعني
حركه زياده في
المحطات اللي كان فيها كروز اكيد طبعا
بالنسبه لنا كمان مبسوطين
بعمليات المعنى اللي تصير مخالطه بالسفر
بالطائرات
وايضا مكان يعني رابط
تطلع رحلات
على مستوى عالي ان شاء الله في سؤال جميل
هنا يعني نسالك كبير ما هو بالضروره منصب
موضوع قصه طريق الحرير الصيني
اهدافه وش الفائده المرجوه منه لنا في
جيزان بحكم انهم اختاروها يعني
كمقر لكثير من الاستثماراتهم
وليش الامارات لم تكمل بناء الميناء مع
الصين
في كذا دائما تصور انه او قصه شائعه الصين
تبني موانع في دول فقيره بقروض غير قابله
للسداد فتتعثر الدول
فتتملك هذه الموانع وبهذه الطريقه هي يصبح
عندها يعني
قوه سياديه على مواقع استراتيجيه
فالسؤال انا اعرف انه من عده اجزاء بس
خلينا نبدا اول شي نقول وشو طريق الحرير
طبعا يعني نحن نشوف طبعا الصين من الدول
اكبر الدول في العالم
يعني من ناحيه الحركه التجاريه وحركه انا
اكبر الموانع موجوده في الصين واكبر
المصانع موجوده في الصين طبعا احنا عندنا
تجربه يعني مع الشركات الصينيه اليوم من
اجزاء الصناعه الاساسيه يشغل من شركه
صينيه طبعا يعني من المهم يكون عندنا يعني
تبادل تجاري وخطوط ملاحيه مباشره مع الصين
عملنا على ذلك في الحياه الحمد لله اليوم
يعني من اكبر الشركات التي تزور عنوان
السعوديه شركه كوسكو شركه صينيه وايضا
مستثمر في محطه البحر الاحمر فالعلاقه
موجوده ومهمه يكون عندنا يعني خطوط مباشره
مع الصين لتسهيل حركه مرور البضائع وموضوع
انها يعني عندها طريقه انها تبني موانع في
دول ما تستطيع السداد عشان تاخذ هذه
الموانئ انا ما اقدر يمكن اعلق على
الموضوع هذا يعني نحن ممكن اتكلم عن
تجربتنا اللي في المملكه كانت تجربه شراكه
ممتازه ويعني استفدنا من الخبرات الصينيه
وكانت شركناتها وعندك اي اطلاع على موضوع
الميناء اللي في الامارات اللي ما تم لا
والله ما عندي معلومات
في هنا سؤال يقول
لماذا لا يتم اجباره وكالات السيارات على
اخلاء الميناء بدلا من تخزين هناك مما اثر
على اسعار السيارات في السعوديه
اليوم ما هو مكان تخزين يعني هو مكان في
التشغيل يحصل فيه يعني بشكل
مستمر لازم يكون في الحركه تعمل بشكل
مستمر
اليوم نحن في اماكن مخصصه لتخزين السيارات
اذا بستفيد منها التاجر هي متاحه وايضا مع
المناطق اللوجستيه الان
قيد الانشاء هتوفر ايضا خدمات
لتجار السيارات منها طبعا
مناطق لاعاده التصدير وايضا اماكن فلفل
لقطع الغيار ايضا سوف يتم ايضا في مشروع
كبير في ميناء الملك عبدالله على بناء اكو
سيستم لصناعه السيارات
وهذا ايضا الان قيد الانشاء سؤال قبل
الاخير هل في ربط للموانع مع المناطق
اللوجستيه وشبكه القطارات يعني اليوم عندك
اهم ميناء جدا ما هو مربوط ولا قطار
وبالتالي شاحنات تكدس زحمه بعنصر بشري
عالي هل انتم جزء من موضوع الجسر البري
والحديث اللي قاعد يصير فيه طبعا من اهم
المشاريع الان موجوده في منظومه النقل
الخدمات
اليوم الحمد لله صار في ربط الان بين
الجبيل والدمام وربط موجود بين الدمام
والرياض طبعا المشروع هذا حيستكمل طبعا
الربط الى جده من جده الى الى رابغ ورابغ
الى ينبع طبعا اليوم قلنا الحمد لله ما في
تقدس على على بوابات الموانئ بسبب اليوم
الانظمه والمعيد الالكترونيه اللي صارت
لكن حيفيد بتقليل عدد يعني الشاحنات على
الطرق يعني
بزياده الامن والسلام على الطرق وتقليل
تكلفه الصيانه على الطرق وهذا مشروع ان
شاء الله الان يعني
قيد التصميم الان وان شاء الله باذن الله
يعلم من الوزاره على تنفيذه وهذا طبعا
المشروع محوري
الجسر
لنا ان اليوم
الصادر والوارد اليوم يجينا صادر احنا
جينا وارد الى جده نحتاج صادر من المنطقه
الشرقيه فنقدر نربط اليوم هذا المنعم بشكل
بشكل افضل
اخر سؤال
وهو سؤال جيد ينفع يكون الختام برج القادم
يعني احنا لو نتكلم اليوم على ارسم لنا
مشهد الموانئ السعوديه في
2030 2030 من ناحيه وصف رقمي هل نحن نتكلم
على في مانع زياده ولا نفس الموانع سعه
[موسيقى]
النظره تكون الموانع متكامله مانع شامله
بمناطق حره بمناطق لوجستيه
مرتبطه بشكل الحديد مرتبطه ايضا بالمناطق
اللوجستيه المجاوره والمناطق الصناعيه
وتكون ممكن اساسي لجميع القطاعات الاخرى
في المملكه شكرا ابو طلال شكرا وبالتوفيق
في ان نكون محور ربط القارات باذن الله
الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا شكرا لك شكرا لكم
شكرا في اعداد وانتاج الحلقه ياسر كدشة
وضحنا العطاس خلف الكاميرات في تسجيل
الصوت يوسف ابراهيم وفي التحرير محمد
الديني وفي الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن
وفي الاشراف على انتاج رزان الدهيثم هذا
بودكاست سقراط احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]